[Musik]
in unserem lagezentrum vor einer guten
woche da haben wir ihnen diese aufnahmen
hier gezeigt des amerikanischen
satelliten des unternehmens max a dieser
gigantische russische konsul julian der
sich da in bewegung gesetzt hatte vom
norden in richtung kiew und jetzt vor
wenigen stunden haben uns neue
satellitenaufnahmen erreicht die zeigen
dass mit diesem konvoi etwas geschehen
ist was ist dass julian er ganz genau
mag sie hatten ja vor einer woche die
informationen über diese bilder erhalten
das ist ein 60 km langer konvoi von
belarus kommen sich auf kiew zubewegte
der blick dann stecken er blieb einfach
deshalb stecken weil man zuerst
versuchte nach kiew reinzukommen die eu
keine amtlich verteidigt und dieser
konnte weder vor noch zurück jetzt eine
woche später etwa eine woche später
haben wir neue sollen die aufnahmen von
max und wir sehen dass dieser kunde
versucht hat sich aufzulösen also
selbstverständlich da schon mehr als
2.000 lkw drin die wurden aufgelöst und
vor allem die haben schutz bekommen
vielleicht kann man mit dem ersten bild
mal anfang
okay und sagte hier das erste danach
gehen sie nämlich schutzlos auf der
straße so ganz genau wir haben gesagt
dass teilweise drei hinter nebeneinander
stehen und hunderte vielleicht tausende
hintereinander stehen und das über 60
kilometer wenn wir uns das neue angucken
dann sehen wir dass es zwar immer noch
welche gibt auf diesen straßen teilweise
auch noch zwei nebeneinander aber und
das ist ganz neu ich mache ja so mal
einen moment ich geb dir den stift
was wir was sie hier sehen das ist eine
verteidigung dieses converse das sind
mehrfach raketenwerfer
höchstwahrscheinlich die eben in eine
bestimmte richtung gerichtet sind und
dort theoretisch sollte jemand diesen
konnte angreifen wie verteidigen können
auch hier sehen wir verschiedene
stellungen ob man das singer weise nicht
genau auch das sieht man immer an diesen
forschen an diesen spuren das könnten
luftabwehrsysteme sein oder ähnliches
man hat sich dort um gestellt sieht man
auch noch mal deutlicher auf dem
nächsten bild die auflösung vielleicht
nicht ganz so gut aber was man hier gut
sieht sind diese spuren im schnee und
immer da wo die spuren enden da steht am
ende auch ein russisches militärfahrzeug
hier in eine straße darauf noch einzelne
fahrzeuge aber eben hier auf dem feld
mehrfach an mehreren stellen eben in
stellung gegangen der fahrzeuge aus
diesem konvoi womöglich auch eben
teilweise in angriff stellung gegangen
für diese offensive die da auf kiew
droht das wissen wir jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht aber fakt ist diese
gigantische schlange manchem auch gesagt
dieser gigantische stau in wahrheit der
hat sich ein stück weit aufgelöst wir
schauen auf andere aktuelle aufnahmen
die uns erreicht haben julian ein vorort
von kiew hier ist ein kamerateam das
begleitet eine ukrainische einheit man
hört den gefechtslärm gleich und vor
allem sieht man eben die da ja umkehrt
in den vororten geschossen wird wir
haben dieses video ausgewählt und nicht
wegen dieser kampfhandlung sondern was
uns hier vor allem fasziniert ist die
waffenauswahl denn die soldaten die hier
füllt die ukraine im einsatz sind die
haben ja so einen ganzen europäischen
gemischtwarenladen an modernen waffen
dabei wir haben diesmal vorbereitet was
die da alles dabei was inters für waffen
was wir hier sehen ist das was wir
tatsächlich auch erwartet haben wir
haben also auf der anderen seite diese
riesige russische panzer armee mit
tausenden fahrzeugen dem hat die ukraine
und auch sonst fast niemand etwas
entgegen zu bieten auf der anderen seite
sehen wir hier ukrainische einheiten
kleiner einheiten schnelle einheiten die
sich mobil von einem ort zum anderen
bewegen und die waffen die die haben
sind tatsächlich best of the best gegen
panzer gepanzerte fahrzeuge zum einen
kann vollständig die apg 7 das ist ein
altes sowjetisches modell aber weiterhin
sehr effektiv das hat überhaupt da muss
man wirklich genau zielen quasi und dann
auf dem panzer schießen aber wir sehen
hier unten die angler aus großbritannien
wir sehen die 10 90 aus spanien mund und
das ärgert einige in russland ganz
besonders wir sehen die panzerfaust drei
aus deutschland das heißt auch die
deutschen panzer abwehrwaffen von denen
korrigiere mich 1000 geschehen
außensteckdosen 100 aus holland genau
ganz genau sind mittlerweile nicht nur
in lemberg angekommen sondern sind in
und um kiew angekommen wie sehen sie
hier auf dem rücken des soldaten und
werden dort eben gegen russische
einheiten eingesetzt ich vermute dass
der sinn dieser aufnahmen auch war das
genau klar zu machen der russischen
seite schaut mal hier was wir
mittlerweile alles haben denn was schon
auffällig war in diesem video wie viele
dieser waffen zu sehen war wenn wir
wissen wie groß dieses land ist wie
verhältnismäßig wenige waffen angekommen
sind dann ist davon auszugehen dass
nicht jeder ukrainische trupp so viele
anti panzer waffen leider muss man sagen
dabei hat aber hier mal eine art auswahl
die da präsentiert wird das ist
mittlerweile alles bei uns angekommen
was wir auch vorbereitet haben julian
ist ein ja dramatisches spektakuläres
drohnen feet aus der ukraine ich spüre
ein stück weit vor und du erklärst und
was wir gleich sehen werden ab sekunde
20 erkennt man sehr genau was hier
gleich alles passiert ja was wir hier
sehen ist einer der russischen panzer
vorstöße in richtung hauptstadt kiew wir
befinden uns hier an der grenze des
vorortes pro vary etwa also nur zehn
kilometer zur grenze von 4 23 meter zum
zentrum käfer das eine riesige stadt und
wir sehen diesen panzer konvoi der und
das muss man wieder sagen verwundert uns
wie schon so oft die hauptstraße nimmt
weder von links noch von rechts
abgesichert ist keine luftüberwachung
hat wir sehen hier oben das nokia asha
drohen adidas filmt und der cs gleich
und warum geht schon los von
ukrainischer artillerie angegriffen wird
die panzer die stehen unglaublich eng
das haben wir immer wieder gesagt wie
merkwürdig diese fahrzeuge geparkt sind
dass man eigentlich nicht so eng man
sieht ja auch das kreuz und quer geparkt
wird man sich auch womöglich gegenseitig
blockiert gleich denn julian hat schon
gesagt hier unten sieht man bereits den
ersten einschlag ganz klassisch auch für
seinen angriff man trifft erst das erste
fahrzeug und gleich werden wir noch
sehen dass die zweite rakete hier hinten
einschlägt und dann ist dieser konvoi
ein stückweit sozusagen ausgeliefert wir
sehen dass also hier unten der erste
treffer dann oben der zweite treffer und
dann wird in diesem konvoi weiter
reingeschossen und die fahrzeuge ja die
stehen da und können eigentlich nicht
viel machen und am ende flüchten sie
wieder am ende verlassen hier in
südlicher richtung von hier aus belgrad
kiew gewesen sie für je nach norden
wieder zurück ziehen sich zurück das ist
wirklich kaum zu glauben das ist eine
absolute übermacht hier also wirklich
eine extreme übermacht an soldaten am
material die aber weil sie eben in einen
hinterhalt sich ohne not offenbar
bewegen und dort dezimiert werden wir
wissen dass der kommandant dieser
einheit gestorben ist bei diesem angriff
der wohl zwischen den panzern sich
bewegt hat wurden sie dann
zurückgeschlagen und haben diesen oft
bovary wieder in richtung
nordosten verlassen also einer der
angriffe der abgewählt wird heute wir
haben noch mal eine ganz ähnliche
situation und die aber auch hier wieder
gleich dramatischer gefechtslärm
diese situationen gefilmt aus der
perspektive von gewöhnlichen fußsoldaten
sozusagen
und auch hier sehen wir dass das alles
nicht so taktisch vor sich geht wie man
das von gut ausgebildeten gut
ausgerüsteten erfahrenen soldaten
erwarten würden und ganz wichtig dass
und rohstoffe das ist einen russischen
von einem russischen soldaten in den
russischen sozialen medien
veröffentlicht worden wir sehen vor
allem diesen unterschied die ukraine wir
haben vorher gesehen bewegen sich hinter
bäumen bewegen sich in kleinen
flusstälern usw die russen kennen das
gebiet nicht die haben auch keine
moderne gps technik zum großen teil
deshalb müssen die auf den hauptstraßen
sich bewegen und die hauptstraßen sind
natürlich das was von den ukrainern
überwacht wird und was von drohnen
überwacht wird und was dann beschossen
wird wir sehen dass hier eine russische
fuß einheit man möchte versagen immer
einmal eine fuß einheit hat man also
daraus gelernt und ist von seinem panzer
runtergekommen aber die wird hier
angegriffen und sie geht nicht links
oder rechts von der strasse runter wie
es eine moderne armee machen würde so
haben sie muss weiter auf der straße
geradeaus laufen und ist auch im
präsentiert hat ist auf dem
präsentierteller verliert auf dem weg
noch equipment sehen wir den magazin
legen also da geht ganz viel drunter und
drüber ich habe vorher mit einem
bundeswehroffizier noch drüber
gesprochen er sagte erstens viele der
soldaten des wirkt als hätten die gar
keine schutzwesten an also auch hier
wieder das ausrüstungs thema und dass
das nach chaotischer flucht nach
volkssturm nach was auch immer aussieht
aber eben nicht nach dieser gut
ausgerüsteten ausgebildeten armee die
die rüsten zumindest selbst immer wieder
geglaubt haben die sie da haben das habe
nicht nur die russen glaub ich glaube
dieser mythos der russischen moderne
armee hat sich mittlerweile erledigt wir
sehen wie diese amir vorstößt und sie
macht es wie vor 50 jahren lasst uns zum
abschluss noch einmal auf die karte
gucken wir haben dieses vereinfachte
schaubild wo gerade russische truppen in
stellung gegangen sind sie sehen hier
diese roten bereich also aus dem norden
da kamen die offensive das erste was wir
gesehen haben julian worüber wir schon
vor einer woche gesprochen haben das war
der vorstoß hier aus dem westen der
hatte dann teilweise du korrigiert mich
ist zum stocken gekommen dann haben wir
einen neuen vorstoß gesehen hier über
den osten wo ist in den letzten 24
stunden ein weiterer vorstoß gelungen
ich habe gehört etwa drei kilometer
sollen die russen am boden gut gemacht
haben wo läuft das gerade was wir gerade
gesehen haben das video von vorgestern
der angriff oft pro watt pro war ist
hier also ganz neben kiew dort versucht
man von norden vorzustoßen das hat
überhaupt nicht funktioniert wir sehen
aber dass im westen was das gerade
gesagt wir sind also hier führt ihn
danach computer danach kommt der host
ohne hast du mit tarot der genau der
hubschrauber ist alles alles klar
richtig aber da festigen sich die russen
da gab es auch keine erfolgreiche
ukrainisch gegenoffensive das heißt nur
etwa acht kilometer ab acht kilometer
vor cap im nordwesten der stadt gibt es
mittlerweile feste russische stellungen
nicht los dass die dort durchfahren
sondern die haben die häuser besetzt die
rechnungen dort stellung ein und
bereiten sich sozusagen auf einen ja
auch ein nissan sitz krieg aber auf eine
lange blockade von tier vor die da oben
schon funktioniert wir sehen aber im
süden von kiel vor und auch im osten ist
die stadt noch weitestgehend zu
erreichen hören wir immer vielen vielen
dank für deine analyse und seine
einschätzung und mit dieser analyse
machen wir hier weiter bei bild live